so I talked with the rather curious
title Shor's algorithm is scary now now
I give this talk a few times and I can
never remember actually what title I've
used because you're going to lots of
different conferences and use lots of
different titles and see which one works
best and judging by the emptiness of the
room this is obviously a crap title but
what I did today was I had to check on
the agenda to see what title I'd use to
keep it consistent but earlier this week
I was in or last week I was in France
and I was using that title which
surprisingly that one was full so
obviously the jargon worked better in
Grenoble than in London I quite like
this title which is coming up in some
other conference somewhere next month
and that might be in DC Porto actually
so if anybody doubles up it is the same
talk but you know it's got a better
title so it'd be cooler but this is
actually my favorite title because it
conveys what I think is the essential
quality of quantum computing which is it
uses many worlds to solve the unsolvable
so that that's my favorite art for the
talk so that's the one that I like to
stick to so Who am I well I'm James I
used to work for thought works that you
might have heard of I now work for code
Durance that you're less likely to have
heard of but we're similar types of
companies normally at this point I go
through and show people some pictures of
what I've been doing in whatever city
I'm in but since I live just outside
London that's that's a bit hard for me
to do because I just went and had an
early night last night so here's some
here's some pictures I did earlier
here's one from 2017 when I first did
the London math and as my favorite
London marathon because it was my
fastest here's something I often do in
London which is take a photo of my
season ticket to claim back a refund for
when the trains are late there's any
French people and then when you won't
understand that because your trains work
here's me and my daughter in the Tate
Gallery last week we were at an
Exhibition which was really cool
it was somebody called Dora Maar if
you're staying in London and you want
something to do I'd recommend the Dora
Maar exhibition at the Tate London
that's a Picasso painting of Dora Maar
which if you read the caption next to it
she says she always hated the Picasso
paintings over said she painted her as a
miserable figure depicting
the Spanish Civil War apparently this is
what I normally do in London that's us
at Co Durance working and stuff and
something that I often do when I'm in
the UK is sit down and watch the cricket
anybody that's not British won't
understand a word of that so I advise
you not to look at that picture and when
I first started talking about quantum
computing like a couple years ago
because I knew so little about the
subject I had to make jokes about my
daughter's cat clementines cat and
compare it to Schrodinger's cat that's
all gone from the presentation now but
just for her sake you know here is me
annoying the cat when I got home drunk
one time and then as anybody that knows
me knows here's a picture of me in my
natural environment which is obviously
the pub so that's from sometime last
year so that's enough of London what are
we going to talk about today well and
this is essentially a talk about
cryptography and the future of
cryptography some of you may have heard
that quantum computers threatened to
break tog Rafi I'll explain how and then
I'll go on to explain what may follow
when our current encryption algorithms
are no good to us anymore so first of
all I'll start with a quick 101 on
cryptography I'm hoping people in the
room understand cryptography algorithms
everybody got some basis on them so
that's the first section but before we
dive into that
here's a quick pub quiz which I do know
is a thing in this country I always have
to ask if I'm not in the UK
anybody know who these three gentlemen
are anybody want to guess who these
three gentlemen are go no it is Ellis
Williamson and Cox anybody heard of them
no I thought not we'll come back to them
later anybody want to hazard a guess at
these two do you want to have a guess no
notnot wrong algorithm they're different
Hillman
okay what about these three yes
Rivest Shamir and Adleman we will come
back to them I fully apologize about the
lack of diversity of those three slides
nothing I can do about history I'm
afraid but moving forward here's some
diversity cuz there's two women on this
slide when we talk about cryptography
the whole purpose of it is is that Alice
is trying to send a message to Bob and
Eve is the evil eavesdropper so she's
trying to read the message now the key
to this whole triangle is that Eve needs
to read the message without them knowing
there is no value in Eve reading the
message if both parties or one of the
parties know that the message has been
intercepted that was in Australia
brilliantly during war time when the the
Allies didn't want the Germans to know
that we didn't said to the messages so
we didn't actually act on all the
intelligence we picked up there was
always a committee decision on to
whether to act on it or not because if
the Germans knew they would have changed
the Enigma codes so modern cryptography
is essentially based on public key
exchange essentially to cut a long story
short as I'm sure you all know it's all
based around finding a mathematical
operation that is easy to do in one
direction and hard to do in the other so
most algorithms that the most common is
that you rely on two large prime numbers
multiply them together that's dead easy
factorizing them is very very hard it's
of sub exponential complexity with with
the best known classical algorithm so
French essentially a 3,000 bit key would
if you could build a computer using
every electron in the universe as a
computational bit it would take that
computer longer than the lifetime of the
universe to decrypt at 3000 bit key so
we can assume that RSA keys are safe
from attack from a classical computer
however why are we talking about it then
because there is something called
quantum computers so does anybody in
this room works with a quantum computer
at all no nobody just me okay here's
another guest whose session this person
is quite famous can anybody know who
that is
no okay that's max planck now the reason
why I'm showing Max Planck is because I
want to give a quote from Max Planck
it's actually a paraphrasing of a quote
science advances one funeral at a time
now what max planks point was with that
is that when you introduce a new idea
into science you very rarely persuade
the the holders of the existing ideas to
change their views but what has tended
to happen throughout the history of
science as it advances is that those old
ideas die out as the people that held
them die out and we saw that happening
throughout the 20th century people
refused to let go of their notions of
Newtonian physics because they could see
and feel that they refused to take on
quantum physics and what I urged people
to do when you're thinking about quantum
computers and quantum mechanics is to
try and let go some of those
preconceptions you've got about the way
the world works
because if you can't do that then you'll
probably look at a talk like this and
look at the technology involved and just
not believe it so quantum computers and
classical computers firstly classical
computers work with bits and logic gates
on the left is an or gate it's it's
essentially an or gate if either a or b
is closed the bulb comes on the right
hand side what we see there is a diagram
representing I think there or not a NAND
gates I can't remember exactly what the
shapes are but essentially that's a
circuit diagram that implements 16-bit
floating-point arithmetic the inputs
come from the top and the outputs go
somewhere that is all classical
computers do they use logic gates to
manipulate zeros and ones to get more
complex results so by using literally
millions of those gates in sequences
they do all the wonderful things that we
know they can do but that is that's all
they do
they manipulate zeros and ones what's a
quantum computer well it has a thing
called a qubit it's anybody heard of a
qubit yeah some nods in the room good so
like a classical bit they will tell you
that they're 0 or 1 if you observe their
value if you don't or prior to you
observing their value the chances are
they hold both values 0 and 1
simultaneously that becomes obviously
important later and I'll explain a bit
about Shor's algorithm but essentially
what this means is in a quantum
computer you can carry out calculations
simultaneously on a vast number vast
number of numbers basically that's
called superposition in all bar the
simplest states the qubits will be in
superposition here's a little diagram
called the Bloch sphere that represents
the quantum state of a qubit the little
toasting-fork I believe is the Greek
letter psi that represents the quantum
state if the quantum state is pointing
straight upwards in this picture and you
measure the value of that qubit it will
tell you it's zero 100% of the time if
the toasting-fork is pointing straight
down it will tell you it's one 100% of
the time
if the toasting-fork is anywhere else on
the surface of that sphere it's actually
holding both values but when you measure
it it will tell you 0 or 1 on a
probabilistic basis depending on which
one it was closer to that's not quite
the truth but it's good enough for this
talk it's more complex than that to do
with modular arithmetic and various
theorems ok and you take a load of these
qubits put them together and you were
pushed them through logic gates here's a
set of logic gates just like logic gates
in a classical computer they take one or
more inputs and they may modify the
value of those qubits or they may
influence the value of another qubit and
they're working on the quantum state
they're moving that toasting-fork around
on the surface of the spheres of those
those qubits so that's how we program
quantum computers one of the limitations
is that there are no real abstractions
built on top of the logic gates in that
we have with classical computing right
now there's literally millions of
abstractions built on top of those basic
logic gates so that we never have to
understand how to manipulate them
directly there is no such thing for
quantum computing just yet there are
some libraries that Microsoft have
released which I used to program some of
this stuff but essentially you need to
understand you need to get write down
and understand what the quantum state is
doing and what the gates are going to do
to your qubits it's far too complex a
subject to talk about in 45 minutes so
we'll gloss over it and talk about one
or two important concepts
superposition and interference so I've
mentioned superposition briefly that is
the notion that your qubits are holding
both possible values at any given point
in time which means that for example if
you have four cubits they're all in
superposition you've you've got eight
values there you've got zero three two
seven to manipulate interference well
I'm going to show you some interference
now this will be our first video
interlude this is usually where I forget
to do something and and it doesn't come
up on the screen button let's see if I
can remember everything I think if I
click that oh no that didn't work there
you go
all right let's show time the three of
us have been trying to reproduce the
double slit experiment so this is Ben
this is James and I'm James as well
we've used equipment that you can find
anywhere at well 3d printer maybe yeah
Wow down here we made a frame and a
holder for our double slit we make the
double slit by using a sharp knife in
between some tinfoil here we have a
laser pointer it's the same laser points
that are living in being during the
presentation so who knows I might even
reproduce it if I've got this equipment
but it'll probably end up in the bin
later down this end we've got 3d models
of pen we've got big bed and
medium-sized pen little Ben we left on
the table over there somewhere and
they're holding our screen to receive
the results of social let's see if we
can make a diffraction an interference
pattern at the other end of this desk
very scientifically done this and there
it is can we see the interference
pattern and that is quantum physics in
action as demonstrated for you in the
footworks office thank you very much
well that's perfect for a second okay
why would I show you that by the way I
didn't edit that video one of my
colleagues that was in it edited it
you'll see my editing later and it's
nowhere near as good as that okay so no
not mirrored displays I want to do that
and then where's my presentation there
you go so why did I show you that so
prior to the 19th century it was
believed by all physicists that light
travelled as particles and that was
based on Newton's Sir Isaac Newton's
views that he put down in the 17th
century and he called those particles
corpuscles nobody really challenged that
for a long time until by the start of
the 19th century they were challenging
it so a guy called young and I think
1809 did an experiment where he put me
pretty much what I just did on that desk
pushed light through two slits and his
he was posted in there if light travels
in waves we'll see an interference
pattern on the detector will see dark
patches and light patches will see the
light patches as we saw in my experiment
where the waves positively interfere and
we'll see dark patches where the waves
negatively interfere and cancel each
other out so that experiment was run in
1809 and they said okay hey presto we've
proved that light travels in waves and
everybody was happy for a while until
this man came along no prizes for
guessing here is of course that is
Albert Einstein and just to keep up with
the style of early or I have it Albert
Einstein quote which again is a
paraphrasing God doesn't play dice with
the world
Albert Einstein said this in response to
what we call the Copenhagen
interpretation which is the notion that
the cubit will hold both values and
randomly return one he was uncomfortable
with that view he was uncomfortable with
the notion that there was some kind of
randomness involved and just that words
that would determine outcomes that was
what this quote was based on if you go
on wiki quote you'll see that actually
there are loads and loads of variations
of it so people normally paraphrase it
like that so
18:09 we've proved that light travels in
waves right but hang on a minute it
turns out after Einstein came along that
we realized that light doesn't travel in
waves it travels in discrete particles
called photons and they travel one at a
time when you when you see lights
there's actually millions and millions
and millions of photons that are seeing
your eyes you're not being hit by waves
so in the double slit experiment here's
a picture of it the photons go through
this slit or this slit and they're
incident on the screen so then
physicists in the 20th century started
asking well okay if we accept that light
travels as particles why do we see an
interference pattern that's slightly
uncomfortable so what they came up with
was a notion called wave particle
duality they said okay they're particles
in some ways they're waves in other ways
and that was alright because people said
well okay if they have this wave
particle duality then there's obviously
lots of them going through the slits
simultaneously and they interfere with
nearby photons so that was the
explanation that people had which
prevailed from sort of the start of the
20th century until somewhere around the
1940s 1950s until they became possible
to run that experiment that's depicted
there but it was possible to just fire
one photon at a time from the photon
emitter and detect it so now what you've
got is an experiment where the photons
are definitely interfering with nothing
else there are no other photons to
interfere with and what happens well
something like this happens they land
one at a time on the detector but you
still see an interference pattern now
that is very counterintuitive and it
goes against the notion that of
wave-particle duality and the fact that
they can interfere with each other
because we know we can we've now
guaranteed that there are no other
photons to interfere with them and this
is where the Newton quotes sorry there
Einstein quote about God not playing
dice and the quote about discarding
earlier views comes in because the best
explanation for this is what we call the
many-worlds interpretation of quantum
physics it was first put forward by a
guy called wheeler in the 1950s and what
he said was every photon is not just
taking one discrete path it is taking
every possible path through those double
slits and you may think that there is an
infinite number of paths for that photon
to take but actually there aren't
because space is split up into discrete
units so the thinner you make those
slits the fewer discrete paths it's
possible for the photon to the take but
it is a finite number of paths ok so
what's going on according to many worlds
the photon is taking every possible path
it's only taking one of the paths in the
universe that we can observe but it's
taking all the other paths in other
universes and that is why we're seeing
interference pattern because
interference pattern crosses across all
of the many worlds so that's what's
going on in the double slit experiment
according to the many-worlds
interpretation which I believe is the
only interpretation that fits the facts
the trouble with the Copenhagen
interpretation is that it predicts
future observations but it doesn't
explain them that's a David Deutsch
quote I think I've got that later in the
presentation I can't claim that one
unfortunately why is it important well
in quantum computing this is a quantum
circuit diagram it's called a quantum
score because it looks like musical
notation a bit each of the horizontal
lines represents one of the qubits in
your program and the circular things
represent logic gates and this is a
controlled logic gate which means that
this one is influencing this one and so
on I won't go into what the gates are
except for the Hadamard gate which
basically takes the qubit from the start
state of pointing straight up and
rotates that arrow through 90 degrees
which gives it an exactly 50%
possibility of returning each value and
we use it all the time so what's going
on in that diagram that's called the
quantum Fourier transform it's anybody
heard of the Fourier transform you come
across it in digital signal processing
so I'm not an expert on DSP but from
what I remember from my master's degree
the Fourier transform converts a sound
signal which is obviously in the time
dimension into something in the
frequency dimension which enables
compression of signals now the quantum
Fourier transform does something similar
to the qubits so what's going on in the
quantum Fourier transform is that every
qubit in the picture
they're all in multi in superposition
and they're all influencing each other
they're all interfering with each other
and the transform after its applied
converts everything from a time domain
into a frequency domain and you'll see
in a bit why that's important
unfortunately I could do about five
talks on how the constant Fourier
transform works and still nobody would
understand it fully including me so why
is all of that important why is it
important to quantum computing why is it
important to cryptography well there is
an elephant in the quantum room or in
many quantum rooms and it is this man
does anybody know who this man is
Plue it was in the title of the talk
that's Peter shor I don't have a Peter
shor quote because the whole talks about
Shor's algorithm now what is Shor's
algorithm short algorithm is for
factorizing numbers so we remember from
earlier on RSA relies on the fact that
factorizing a number is is exponentially
difficult so how does it work I'll flash
up the steps here but frankly it's a bit
hard to follow in this form so what I'll
do is I'll run through a simple example
of how Shor's algorithm works
essentially it's you don't just check
every factor up to and including the
number itself like you would do using a
classical algorithm it's based on
finding well I'll explain it better by
doing that this let's say with
factorizing 15 so step one tells us oops
to randomly pick a number less than 15
then we find its period with respect to
15 and then we use some linear algebra
which I'll explain now so let's choose
two randomly which is less than 15 it
would also work with 4 8 7 anything 2 is
not a factor of 15 so we didn't get
lucky so that's step one of the
algorithm now we find the period of 2 to
the X mod 15 so what does this mean 2
squared is 4 2 to the power 3 is 8 2 to
the power 4 is 16 now 16 is 1 mod 15 so
if you carry on raising 2 to successive
powers it go and taking it mod 15 it
goes 1 2 4 8 1 2 4 8 and so on so the
periodicity of 2 with respect to 15 is 4
now what does that tell us it tells us
that 2 squared + 1 + 2 squared - 1
multiplied together is is 0 mod 15 sorry
2 squared times 2 squared is is 1 mod 15
so you can take 1 from both sides and
find that 2 squared + 1 + 2 squared
minus 1 will yield up the factors of the
number because they'll be 0 and mod 15
so let's test that 2 squared minus 1 is
3 2 squared plus 1 is 5 so we factorize
15 great lovely there you go so
obviously that's a trivial example we
know that we all know that 15 is 3 times
5 so one day last year I think it was I
decided to see how Shor's algorithm
really works with a slightly bigger
number and what I did was I I was on the
train and being the sort of sad person I
am I went into Google sheets and I
thought right I'm gonna test out Shor's
algorithm but I'm making a spreadsheet
so what I decided was I chose oops I
didn't mean to do that just added a
random page there I chose an arbitrarily
go on scroll down oh I don't know have I
even got an internet connection that's
disappointing
is this a hardwired internet connection
yeah just bear with me a moment
have I got I'll just stir check this
yeah I'm still connected to the wires oh
that's all right no no it's just taking
your ages to refresh is that will that
give me no I don't have a connector for
it
yeah it might okay I've got a I think I
downloaded this spreadsheet ages ago so
let me just check Oh No maybe I didn't
okay there you go we can see the numbers
so I decided to factorize 1570 and I
chose four first of all and you can see
that I'm raising for two successive
powers and in this column I'm taking it
modulo 1517 so you can see that
eventually that will get back to one and
the the modulus of the wrist the period
of four with respect to that number the
biggest it can possibly be as 1517 which
it isn't if we scroll down we'll see
eventually well I wait for that to
refresh or maybe you'll have to take my
word for it let's just see if my phone
gives me a better internet connection
yeah it's the thing that our God have
taken a an update and I can't see the
button that turns on the oh is it
wireless mobile hotspot there it is
Android changed the layout just let's
just see if that's any better
otherwise he left it out my word on some
of these numbers
okay yeah well that's no better okay so
what we'll wait for that not to worry
what we find is if we work through full
we find that its period is 180 so after
180 turns it gets back to 1 and then it
has a periodicity of 180 so then I tried
as we go through this sheet you'll see
that I tried lots of other numbers the
second sheet is for excuse me with
glasses the second sheet is I was trying
16 and we can see that the period of 16
is 90 the problem with these massive
numbers is that I wanted to have some
integers to work with to actually talk
about it in a conference and it
overflows obviously so you know 16 to
the power 90 is some massive number 4 to
the power 180 is a massive number so
that it's no good eventually if I go to
this sheet here I found that 10 has a
pleasingly low period which potentially
means I can use 10 so the period of 10
is only 15 unfortunately 15 is an odd
number so I couldn't use 10 to
demonstrate the algorithm because I
can't raise 10 to the power 7 and a half
and stay with an integer and then
finally and I can't I'm just gonna get
at some later point I found this 14 has
a period of 24 which does overflow but
importantly 14 to the power 12 it's a
very big number but it doesn't overflow
so I can use 14 to demonstrate how
Shor's algorithm works in real numbers
happily we can get rid of that
spreadsheet which didn't seem to want to
work particularly well and I'll show you
the actual numbers now let's go back to
here and there we go
so we're factorizing 1517 so choose a
number less I'm obviously paraphrasing
what I did that that took me like two
days to find those numbers is to see how
long it takes for google spreadsheets to
update when you drag down those massive
numbers so 10 greatest common divisor
as one period of 10 is 15 so it's an odd
number so I choose another number go
back to the start of the algorithm so I
chose 14 period of 14 is 24 that tells
us that 14 to the power 12 minus 1 is a
multiple of one of the factors so 14 to
the power 12 minus 1 is that massive
number ending in five which is a
multiple of 37 so that gives us one of
the factors 14 to the power 12 plus one
is another massive number ending in a
seven and that is a multiple of 41 those
are the two factors of 1517 so 1517 it's
37 times 41 if you google it on the
Internet there's a really cool video
where he's factorizing a bigger number
and he goes into a bit more detail
unfortunately I also have a link to that
video on here but I don't it's a bit
rubbish sorry about that
anybody know who this person is he's one
of the might he's still a living
scientist probably my famous favorite
scientist that's David Deutsch he wrote
a book called fabric of reality which
some of you may have read there he is
and this is David saying this is a quote
or paraphrasing of a quote from his
other book called the beginning of
infinity in which you've already heard
me say this a good theory not just
doesn't just predict future observations
but it explains all the observations
that you can see and that's that's the
foundation of his epidemiology arguments
to do with with what knowledge means why
am i showing this well because let's
move on to now where is the magic there
Shor's algorithm again now what I just
showed you was a classical computer
simulating Shor's algorithm and if it
wasn't obvious from the spreadsheet I'm
sorry we couldn't see the numbers
particularly well but those numbers are
massive and I'm only factorizing well
1517 is is what an eleven bit number
isn't it so imagine if your factorizing
a 1000 or 2000 or 3000 bit number you
can imagine how vast those numbers get
okay so that's spreadsheet what actually
I've illustrated in their spreadsheet is
if you were to use a classical computer
to go through all of
those routines that I was going through
by hand in that spreadsheet that part of
the algorithm is is actually more
complex than than the most than the best
way of facts rising numbers in a
classical computer it solve exponential
complexity so it's it's intractable
however the magic ensures algorithm is
here a step four so use the quantum
period finding routine to find the
period of a to the X with respect to n
the number we're trying to factorize
because think back to our spreadsheet
with all those massive numbers in it we
don't actually care what each of those
intermediate numbers is we don't care
what all of those numbers are all we
care about in that spreadsheet is the
period so if we could come up with a way
of finding the period of a number but
without having to do all those complex
calculations we potentially have a way
of factorizing a large number now this
is the magic part because using the
quantum the quantum Fourier transform we
can do exactly that
now again I'm going to simplify a bit so
apologies if if anybody looks this up
you'll see a slightly more complex in
this picture but essentially the way
that Shor's algorithm works is I put I
have enough bits
what qubits in my computer that go up to
1517 so I would need eleven qubits here
I put each of these in superposition and
then I do 2 to the power this quantum
register what that will do is raise this
raise to 2 every power from one up to
1517 simultaneously now it can't
possibly do all those calculations in
our universe we know that well it when
the number goes beyond a certain size
and this is where suspending your belief
about how things work comes in because
what's actually happening inside the
quantum computer is because of the
superposition all of those calculations
are taking place they're just taking
place in various other universes but we
know from the double slit experiment
that interference exists across those
universes now what the quantum Fourier
transform gives us is a way of
exploiting that interference paths
to help us discover the periodicity so
if you think back to Young's double-slit
experiment the gaps between the light
spots in the dark spots can be used to
calculate the wavelength of light and
something very similar is happening
Shor's algorithm by looking at the
interference pattern by examining the
interference pattern by using the
quantum Fourier transform it's possible
for us to discover the periodicity of
that function but without having to
calculate all of those values and there
are provably more calculations that can
be done in our universe which is
according to David Deutsch the best
proof so far that the many-worlds
theorem should take primacy over the
Copenhagen interpretation so I urge you
if you're interested to go and read a
bit more about Shor's algorithm because
I've really paraphrased how it works if
you want to see an implementation of
Shor's algorithm using Microsoft Q sharp
you can go to my github there's me
running it to factorize 21 of course I
used a classical computer to simulate a
quantum computer to do that because I
don't have direct access to a quantum
computer not permanently anyway so they
go I factorize 21 using it if you want
to see a better implementation I used to
have a colleague at ThoughtWorks called
Andrew and I asked him to implement it
from first principles he was a grad so
as a much better software developer than
I am obviously because he still is
interested by doing it and he did it in
like half a day and then while I was on
the train from Manchester back to London
he sent me this message saying my my
algorithm works and I factorize 35 it
took that long but which gives you an
idea of how complex it is because what
we're doing is effectively simulating
the the quantum computer we're doing all
of those calculations in my spreadsheet
in in that time so yes so andrew's
implementation is much neater than mine
actually my c-sharp code is better than
his but his Q sharp code the quantum
codes better than mine so I'd go his
blog if I was you so should we care
about this is RSA gonna die is RSA on
the way out well here's an idea of where
we're going with this Shor's algorithm
you need a quantum computer with about
three times as many qubits as the size
of the key so currently we're using RSA
2048 in most implementations so you
would need a quantum computer with about
6,000 qubits to successfully decrypt
that key which I then said on that
bullet point I always forget that bullet
points coming next I also look at that
relation the biggest publicly known gate
logic quantum computer at the moment has
about one hundred qubits so we're quite
a long way away from having a quantum
computer that is truly a threat to our
current encryption algorithms however
Google recently claimed quantum
supremacy now the reason why this is
significant is because we talked a lot
about it in the quantum computing world
what this means is that Google claims
that it has a real-world problem that is
solvable more efficiently with a quantum
computer than a classical computer now
that was I think last October they made
that claim of course it's disputed by
the other big players but what it does
mean almost certainly is that there is
more and more money pouring into quantum
computers I do know that banks because
I've worked with some myself or worked
with people that have worked with some
in the UK banks are working on quantum
algorithms because they promised to help
with things like predicting the future
values of markets so there's a lot of
investment going in and if quantum
supremacy is proven then that investment
will go on probably exponentially so
what do we do if our RSA stops working
well BB 84 is a quantum key distribution
algorithm that I'm going to show you in
a moment and there are other quantum
safe algorithms what disappoints me is
that these algorithms the three I've
picked out there they they already exist
they're implementable in classical
computers and they're provably I say
provably sort of slightly cautiously
because I've been caught in not to say
provably but they're believed to be safe
from quantum attacks those algorithms
there's one called ring learning with
errors that I haven't picked out there
which can be implemented my
understanding is that people are
reluctant to implement them because
they're they impose a performance
penalty because naturally you'd expect
that they're doing
more computation to make the thing
unbreakable by quantum computers so we
can make things quantum safe but we're
not doing it yet is the message coming
along so here are some other algorithms
as I mentioned there's something called
our lwe but the key size is too big the
performance is slow but I'm going to
talk about BB 84 so this is the film
that's edited by me so you'll probably
scoff at the editing and think it's
rubbish because I always do and it
explains why Amazon sent me all that
packaging so I think it's no it's not
that one it's this one here we go yeah
we're going to talk about polarization
light and here we've got my daughter
Clementine I okay and outside what have
we got we've got the cat that is that is
clementines cat and as you can see she
wants to get inside girls does one of
you want to empty this box out just to
show Amazon's packaging and what was it
they sent us through the post well it
was these three tiny pieces of
polarizing light filter okay
now let's run our experiment girls if
you take one Clementine
take another so you take those take
thanks Hank mobile to the window okay so
now the girls have got four three light
filters clementines got to our
Felicity's got one okay so now
Clementine if you hold one light filter
up to the light that's it that's good
now well hold it so this face you right
towards me so it's flat towards me
basket okay now bring the other light
filter up Clementine and that's it now
they're at right angles to each other
and you can see the weather
no light is getting through if you just
rotate it around again so it's the other
way around Clem you can see that when
they're in the same orientation is still
less half the light through so now if
you put them together the other way
around that's it hold them tightly
against one another that's it no light
is getting through one of the filters is
stopping all the light the other filters
stopping the other all the rest of the
light
now if listy get the other filter and
hold it in front so it's touching you
can see still nothing's coming through
the two filters they're touching and on
the back please okay still nothing comes
through the two filters now slip it in
between the two filters that's it
brilliant now hold now twist it twist it
towards you twist it towards you and
make sure they're tight at the top hold
it there
fantastic now you can see what's
happening where there's one filter some
of the light stops where there's three
filters some of the light stops where
there's only two filters all of the
light is stopped okay
what's going on with that it seems like
a counterintuitive result if I put two
filters together I stop all the light if
I introduce a third filter in between
somehow some of the light now gets
through you would think that by
introducing a third filter I'll just
stop more light so what is going on well
well what's happened to there hang on
now that's the one I want isn't it take
that off find my presentation again is
that it no that's my spreadsheet that
didn't work here's the presentation so
there's there's the picture one filter
stops half the light coming through the
window two filters together stop a
hundred percent of the light but by
introducing a third filter
counter-intuitively now it doesn't stop
all the light anymore only stops some of
the light what's going on well light
travels in photons we know that from
earlier photons have an orientation it
can be thought of as an orientation
again it's a bit of a stylization so
there you go there there and white light
coming through the window in my house
is oriented randomly so let's think of
that first filter as being vertically
aligned so if those photons are
vertically aligned they'll get through
any photon that is horizontally aligned
will not get through okay anything in
between might get through so because
they're in a random orientation and
there's enough of them that means that
50% of the light gets through but it
doesn't just let them through they are
now all oriented vertically a bit like
when we observe the value of a qubit the
photons are a quantum system you can use
photons as qubits so by going through
the filter they not only stop half of
them they force the other half to be
vertically aligned so what that means is
when we introduce the second filter at
right angles to the first filter they
are all at right angles to that second
filter so absolutely none of them will
get through and that's what we saw when
we just saw two filters together so then
why does introducing the third filter
let light through well again the first
filter stops 50% of the light but now
I'm gonna put a second filter in between
but it's going to be at 45 degrees to
that first filter so what does that mean
well it then lets through 25% of the
original photons but now they're
diagonal okay whereas before when they
hit that other filter they were
horizontal sorry they were vertical so
now you can see that exactly 50% of
those will get through so by introducing
that third filter in between we let more
light through so 12 and 1/2 percent of
the light gets through in that 3 filter
arrangement why is that important well
what we're illustrating here is the
whole notion that I mentioned right at
the start of observing a quantum system
may change its value we can use photons
as a quantum system and most importantly
for this talk we can use photons to
implement something called BB 84
benetton Brassard 84 which is a provably
secure quantum key distribution
algorithm how does it work well
Alice and Bob are trying to send each
other a message she uses either photons
oriented like that to send zeros and
ones or photons oriented diagonally to
send zeros and ones so she sends though
one of those for a zero one of these for
a one and she randomly chooses whether
to use the horizontal and a vertical
basis or the diagonal basis for each of
the bits in her key so what she then
does is send the key to Bob there's the
key the key is random it's provably
secure provided that the key is truly
random and longer than the message that
you're sending that's that's a detailed
so she sends the key to Bob now Bob
doesn't know what basis what measurement
basis Alice used at each stage okay so
he has to randomly choose whether to
measure it like that or like that okay
so he takes his own measurements he
chooses a random basis and he takes a
measurement and you can see that
sometimes he chose the right basis which
means he'll get the right measurement in
those cases he happened to choose the
correct basis and the other case is he
chose the wrong basis so sometimes he
got the right measurement sometimes he
got the wrong measurement why does that
matter well because then the next stage
is Bob tells Alice what basis he used at
each stage and Alice tells Bob so
wherever their basis agreed they discard
the rest of the numbers and what's left
is the key now all of that sounds a bit
why is that provably secure well it's
because if Eve eavesdropped the message
she also doesn't know what basis was
used by Alice when she has to eavesdrop
the message and she can't possibly know
what the orientation of the photon was
before she measured it so in every case
where she got it wrong so in these red
cases here all she could do was send
another photon on to Bob which
twenty-five percent of the time or 50
percent
I can't remember we'll have the wrong
measurements so Bob will detect the
wrong measurement okay so what that
means is Anacin Bob take a pre agreed
subset of their key and they compare it
to each other so the key has to be super
longer than the message you're sending
and if Bob detected the correct values
they know they weren't eavesdropped if
Bob detected the wrong values they know
that somebody eavesdrop the key so
therefore all they have to do is send
the key again and again and again until
it's not eavesdropped if Eve carries on
eavesdropping or you don't send the
message so what you've got is a provably
secure key distribution algorithm and
not only is it provably secure it is
already in use around the world here are
some examples where that though these
are actually deployed qkd networks one
of the chinese ones which i may or may
not have on this slide yeah it relays
the photons up to a satellite which then
has a satellite repeater and sends
another photon down the problem with
doing that is you have to trust the
satellite I'm not sure I would trust a
Chinese satellite but hey and in the UK
right now there is a consortium of
companies that are working together to
and here's a demonstration I saw
actually in this building just before
Christmas where they are actually there
there's 40 kilometers or no 25
kilometers of fiber optic cable there
between the left-hand thing and the
right-hand thing and there they're doing
quantum key distribution over that
fiber-optic network and the point about
this is that BT is one of the companies
in this consortium so what they're
trying to do is to put qkd onto the
existing fiber network in the UK it's
it's it's a way off being commercially
viable but it's there so qkd potentially
offers us a way out of the quantum
cryptography apocalypse and it is in use
already so I'm going to finish with a
brief history lesson
now you remember those middle-aged white
gentlemen from the very start of the
talk
so why did I show you pictures of them
well this is the history of public key
cryptography as far as we know it
Diffie and Hellman published their paper
in 1976 that was the first time if
anybody demonstrated public key exchange
then RSA came along in 1977
so Rivest Shah Shamir Adelman they
published RSA their paper they patented
RSA there was all sorts of things with
it and we're still using RSA today so
that's what we understand of the history
of public key cryptography but and
there's a big but in 1997 the British
government according to they released
information that those three gentlemen
Cox Williamson and Ellis they worked for
gc8 GCHQ they in other words the British
secret services they've been using
something that was almost identical to
RSA for some years it's never been
specified exactly how long they've been
doing it but my point is the British
secret service were using public key
cryptography public key exchange before
some years before RSA and diffie-hellman
we're a thing why is that important well
right now RSA is secure however I know
for 100% fact that all of the secret
services all over the world are
currently listening and snooping on all
of our encrypted RSA traffic it's going
over public networks so if you're
sending a message that's RSA encrypted
nobody can read it today nobody can read
it tomorrow probably not for a few years
but if you care about that message being
secured 10 years from now you need to be
already thinking about using post
quantum algorithms and my point is that
exactly that if we care about our
privacy going into the future that's
what we need to do in technology is to
encourage people to start thinking about
those post quantum cryptography
algorithms right now thank you very much
I can take questions I think if
anybody's got any nobody ever asked me a
question sometimes people ask about the
Pratchett book on there but yes sir okay
the question was I've played with the
quantum computer what did it do there's
a couple of times one time in the back
end of 2018 with in partnership with a
couple of companies from Cambridge and
Oxford University and Cambridge
University and IBM IBM gave us backdoor
access to their public quantum computers
the the 20 qubit machine that is running
in America and we used them to do
something called quantum chemistry this
is slightly less scary than than
cryptography most organic compounds are
too complex to simulate in a classical
computer the reason why it's important
to simulate them is that we know the
chemical structure of things in terms of
what atoms it contains and we know a
little bit about whether they're
covalent bonds and certain things like
that
but what happens in a in an organic
molecule or indeed any molecule is that
the atoms in the molecule settle down to
the lowest energy state which is called
the ground state and what that means is
that the angles between the bonds the
angles of the bonds and the distance
between each of the atoms varies and
that's a hugely complex equation which
is the energy equation and one thing
that quantum computers do really well is
optimize multivariate equations which is
why they're also interesting to the
financial industry so the promise the
big non-scary promise and a non
money-making promise of quantum
computers is that if we understand
organic chemistry better for example we
can we can synthesize drugs better but
also we can has anybody heard of the
harbour process for synthesizing ammonia
probably studied it at school I did it
uses something called iron molybdenum
bean plants use iron molybdenum to take
out my spirit nitrogen and fix it and
make
and they do it with no energy uptake the
harbor process takes according to some
estimates up to five percent of all the
world's natural gas to make fertilizer
if we understand how I managed mmm works
the exact structure we could synthesize
it and use that and do away with the
harbour process so quantum chemistry is
a massive thing for quantum computers
that's that's the the biggest good thing
about them so what we did on that IBM
computer was simulate a smaller molecule
to discover its its actual structure it
was an academic exercise because with
only 20 cubits you can only simulate
something with up to about 10 atoms in
it so what we were doing was simulating
something that's actually simulated well
on a classical computer but that's what
we did then and the other time I've
played with them which is much less
interesting is in UCL in London there's
a place called Landorus London's centre
of nanotechnology which is just by
Euston station and no one point in that
direction because it's more like that
direction isn't it
and they've got some quantum computers
that they're using not to actually do
computation but to study the material
science of how to build qubits so I've
got a picture of me standing in front of
one of these things but it's very boring
looking it's just a big white fridge and
yeah they just explained to me how they
were using these basically arrays of
qubits to understand how to pass
messages to them and infamous esday
anybody got any other questions yes sir
okay if you pretty much the order that
they're on the screen I laid them out in
that order these two by John Gribben
John Gribben writes for I think the New
Scientist so he's effectively a popular
science writer so those two I found very
very easy to read and then this one is
where I got the best explanation that
I've seen so far that's what I use to do
the quantum algorithms that I've
implemented and because that's that's
got some actual quantum code in it and
then this one that's a bit more complex
it goes into more detail about what's
going on in the quantum mechanics but I
found that one really useful to
understand the equations so to help me
to start to build a quantum
simulator basically a quantum computer
simulator because it uses sort of vector
and array mathematics a lot to to change
the state of the quantum to change the
quantum states and yeah the carpet
people is on there because I don't know
where the terry pratchet studied quantum
physics or anything but there's a race
of people in the carpet people that can
see every possible future and it's
almost like he was writing with some
insight into how the Copenhagen
interpretation works because it wasn't
until they chose a possible future that
everything crystallized into what was
going to happen it's an interesting book
anybody else are we ready for lunch oh
yes sir
okay so the question was do the
different possibilities defect affect
how deterministic the outcome can be so
some quantum algorithms are
non-deterministic so they use the array
of different inputs to do like Monte
Carlo type simulations and then you run
them tens of thousands of times and see
which one happens most often but of
course so that's one way of using them
on the other hand if you take Shor's
algorithm that doesn't actually care
about those different results so it
doesn't care what state it was because
all it cares about is the periodicity so
Shor's algorithm is a deterministic
algorithm so it depends on how you write
your algorithms so they're either
deterministic like sure because they're
using a Fourier transform or they're
non-deterministic like like a Monte
Carlo simulation and then you just run
it over and over and over again so it
depends I'm a consultant I say it
depends a lot any anybody else great
well thank you very much all for coming
I hope you enjoyed it and give a
feedback on the way up thank you
[Applause]